protesters shutting down New York City's
Subway and demanding murder charges for
the Marine who put Jordan Neely in a
chokehold
[Applause]
the agitators not only blocking the
tracks but stopping people from getting
off the train
are these 12 people were arrested for
jumping onto the tracks and clashing
with police during the dangerous display
a grand jury could decide as soon as
this week if the Marine who put Neely in
that Chokehold could face charges the
Marine claims he never intended to harm
Neely I got a lot of thoughts here judge
one of the things is that you have these
liberal white women telling black guys
who are trying to go to work on the
train that they don't understand the
racism that is being perpetrated on the
train
you know the amazing part of this is I
look at all those people and I say to
myself why don't they protest on behalf
of the mentally ill in this city
mentally ill like Neely who was on a uh
I think it's a top 50 list of people who
are in desperate need of hospitalization
and Urgent Care based upon his level of
mental illness he was a schizophrenic he
suffered from PTSD and and depression uh
sometimes I think Dana that most of the
people who protest don't even know what
they're protesting about you know
whether they want to stop a subway
system or they want to stop traffic for
environmental crimes or they want to you
know destroy paintings they just do it
to fight about something and it's very
very disappointing the the problem in
this case I don't want to get into the
facts again but when a guy says he's
ready to die if you're a cop or if
you're in the military that is special
meaning to you especially if he's
running around threatening people and
and five people may made phone calls I
just wish that people understood more
than the surface level of what's going
on actually I was going to ask Greg
about that because the initial storyline
didn't include lots of other things that
you found out which included something
that happens after the Chokehold right
well he was placed in the recovery
position by somebody was looking out for
him which was the guy that had put him
into restraint along with two other men
one of them wasn't white so I don't know
where you get your racist uh your racist
I don't know assumption there but it's
easy because these people are idiots
these people don't work they have the
time to interview interfere with other
people's jobs these people have nothing
to do and this story is such a good
story because it reveals that the
variables don't matter to them they want
to make this into another George Floyd
but this guy actually attacks people and
was a danger to himself and a danger to
others we can talk by the way we can
talk about this
and no one could counter us because
we've been talking about Mental Health
on this show while the rest of those
jackasses that you're looking at right
there ignored the problems on the street
everybody here talked about it we talked
about it passionately we wanted
something done we pleaded with de Blasio
we pleaded with anybody and to please
help us we could see the city so when
these people talk about compassion
they're all full of crap and I I said
this I don't know a couple days ago once
you become a danger to others then you
become to a danger to yourself unless
you're on a subway with those cowards
then you can get away with murder
because these people would lift a finger
to help you this is what
I'm surprised like hell if I was still a
journalist my headline in in USA Today I
think was beloved street performer I
would have said Heroes protect horrified
strap hangers because that's what
happened I noticed that too they was
like oh he was a Charming Michael
Jackson impersonator yes but and in
addition to that Jesse there were other
problems 43 arrests so the New York
Times did a great piece on this today on
the front page about 3 000 words on
Neely and the Marine didn't find a thing
on the Marine now if the New York Times
is a deep dive on your life and they
don't find a tweet or a picture of you
saying okay or anything that they can
call you some sort of racist about the
guy is clean and they ask the question
at the top was this a citizen trying to
stop someone from hurting others or an
overreaction to a common New York
encounter with a person with mental
illness and if you read the article they
answer the question he was trying to
protect others because not only was easy
on the top 50 list by the way do you
know how hard it is to be on a top 50
list in New York City 8 million people
that is really difficult he was
involuntarily committed to mental
institutions numerous times he was a
heavy drug abuser he had four instances
of punching people in the face women two
of those instances were on the subway
and he actually threatened to kill a
Subway worker he tried to banged on the
door threatened to kill her to get the
kidnapping the kidnapping of the
seven-year-old and then this so he
bunches that old woman's face out breaks
her eye sock and it knows he gets in
front of this judge Ellen bibin Cuomo
appointee and judge you're familiar with
this she's on the alternative to
incarceration Court which is where they
take violent felons and they make them
go to rehab so she white liberal woman
judge
Cooks up a deal with another white
liberal woman the prosecutor Mary weisen
Gerber probably a brag lady and they
make this guy go to rehab in 13 days he
abandons the facility and then they
catch up with them acting deranged and
he starts peeing on everybody and then
they catch him another time and police
have to kick him out of the Subway and
then they catch him a third time and
this is what the Outreach worker said he
was aggressive incoherent and could be a
harm to himself and others if left
treated a couple days later this is what
happens he was not moonwalking on the
subway he was an imminent danger to
other people threatening hell for junior
wrap us up anything you want to say here
I'm struck by the family's quarreling I
hope if there's anything that the
political you have the the deceased
family uh saying that it was an
admission of guilt because of what the
the Marines said that he'd never
intended to harm uh I've not seen all
the facts but I have to think he he
didn't do that and I certainly don't
think that was an admission of admission
of guilt I'm reminded of those families
in South Carolina was that horrible
shooting about a decade ago and the
families immediately forgave the young
man who came to church and shot and
during a prayer service and they
immediately forgave this young man that
I think a lot of people maybe even some
around the table might not have been
forgiven so quickly something like that
happening two we need to know all the
facts here because I I think at the very
beginning judge I'm about to agree with
you I know you want to disagree with me
but let me get to the point I I think
there was a reaction from some
particularly these protests and
protesters that somehow another this
young man was was uh there was a
reaction that was greater than the force
if the law reads clearly if you have an
actual perceived threat you're allowed
to respond proportionate to that threat
so I don't know what that young man uh
Jordan nearly thought when he was on
that train there seemed to be others on
that train there were those that said it
took him 15 minutes to respond to Cops
it only took them six minutes so I want
all of the facts uh to come out here
before we we rush the Judgment the
protesters are embarrassing in a lot of
ways because I don't think they know the
fact facts and listening blocking people
from getting off the train who are going
about their lives working and taking
care of their kids and taking care of
their lives that's not not the right way
to do this I hope we have a flooding of
facts in his own uh more quickly than
not and then we're able all all to react
I think more uh more responsibly yeah
just one more thing these protesters
were fighting with the police you know
the police were there in six minutes and
what I don't understand is how they're
so ready to fight with the police the
police had nothing to do with his death
you know it's just this this automatic
beat the cops right all right uh good
talk everyone coming up legendary actor
Richard Richard Dreyfuss says
Hollywood's turn toward woke diversity
it's making him sick hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now